m
ils étaient plus de 4500 personnes à
être venus rencontrer à mal ce vendredi
22 avril au jardin de l'état
mama figure spirituelle international
surnommé sainte du kerala la présidente
du département nassimah dindar a
souhaité l'accueillir au jardin de
l'état afin que les réunionnais puissent
obtenir le darshan une étreinte de
quelques secondes
il ya beaucoup de gens qui attend lama
au fond en attend une mère une maman il
n'est pas question là de religion ou de
religiosité mais bien d'une figure
emblématique qui représente et qui
véhiculent l'amour et je crois que dans
cette période un peu tourmenté où il y a
beaucoup d'événements de guerre de
violence négative à porter cette
dimension universelle tout simplement du
partage de l'amour de la mère de tous va
je crois que il faut le prendre
des allées pleines à craquer ils étaient
des centaines à avoir patienté dès le
matin pour obtenir le précieux câlin un
véritable engouement pour cette indienne
de 62 ans qui part cette fameuse
étreinte transforme l'énergie négative
en amour et en paix à faire un gros gros
câlin
une dame extraordinaire voire pourquoi
pas quelques uns de ses bras c'est pas
du n'importe quoi s'est hissé non il
suffit de laisser parler son coeur pour
dire je t'aime à quelqu'un qu'on ne
connaît pas être là avec quelqu'un qui
n'est qu'amour baisse est obligé d'être
là ce soir à ma pratique le darshan
depuis 30 ans et à être un plus de 34
millions de personnes dans le monde
entier depuis l'âge de 9 ans à ma vient
en aide aux personnes en souffrance via
des associations humanitaires